I chose the name the last bookstore
because at the time Porter's was going
out of business and a lot of other
little bookstores were going out of
business and it was just in the news a
lot
there's press about books going away and
you know ebooks taking over but people
just don't like to lose something that
they've loved for centuries I think that
the digital age has made print books
more popular in a weird way it just made
everyone come out of the woodwork who
really wants to see books survived and
it's created quite a bit of loyalty I
think among people who really love books
some people prefer physical tactile
objects and some people prefer clicking
a button and having something
instantaneously there's room for both I
think I hope
[Music]
all right I'm gonna put my shoes on
my name is Josh Spencer I own the last
bookstore and I'm a father and a husband
and a paraplegic before my injury I was
really active you know I served and
lifted weights and played volleyball and
hiked and you know I was very outdoorsy
I was riding a moped and got hit by a
car and I was in the hospital for like
three months they did spinal surgery so
we can't really move after that and I
had broken pelvis and collapsed lung and
broken shoulder and skin ripped off my
my whole hand
so yeah there was definitely years of
struggling with that and trying that out
and trying to figure out how can i still
be a man when I'm half paralyzed and how
can I succeed in this world and how can
I have a family if I want that I just
coming to terms with all these things it
took quite a few years I went through
depression just everything was a
challenge everything is difficult you
know I had to I had to really learn how
to readjust my mind and change my
perception so that things that would
seem difficult wasn't necessarily harder
it's just different so it took a decade
I guess for me to to readjust we have
one daughter named Eden she's a handful
it's just super smart she's already
super creative and making a mess so I
think she's just showing off how much
she can eat
she loves reading books you know she's
still at the board book pop-up book
stage but Heidi reads to her every night
hopefully we can instill a love reading
in her as she gets older I'm a
bookseller people expect our child to be
more literate I don't really care what
other people think so I'm not gonna try
to make her a bookworm she doesn't want
to be
[Music]
at the warehouse we sort everything that
comes in through big buys that we do or
donations people selling books through
the store we get a lot of inventory that
way people's personal libraries and when
they pass away or when they move when
they're just downsizing for whatever
reason it seems like people are always
selling books and always donating books
so keeps us pretty busy la earthquake
source book to be useful one day so
right now I'm sorting books into various
categories things that would go directly
to the store things that were just gonna
box up but I first started there wasn't
any technology you know you didn't have
smartphones there wasn't databases you
could download with information so I had
to know all this stuff kind of just by
feeling my heart I've been doing this
for so long like I can tell in a split
second if something's too damaged for
anybody to buy we'll keep a lot of books
on hand just to send to hospitals and
schools and whatnot it's kind of a fancy
job for anybody that's really in love
with all different kinds of books and
loves finding buried treasure I found
five hundred bucks one time weird love
letters a pressed pot leaf and A Song of
Solomon book one time and I don't know
if with use but like toilet paper and
you know I hate it when people use
toilet paper from bookmark it's the
worst somebody's got a photocopied cover
of Harry Potter it's like their own
custom-made Kinkos dust jacket it's not
even on that book it's on the the
miracle cosmetic plastic surgery so they
wanted somebody to think they were
reading Harry Potter that weird you see
all kinds of weird stuff like that
yeah like who are these people that you
know do that yeah it's cool and you
never know what to expect it's a
treasure hunt
not just the books themselves but what's
inside yeah this guy works here we found
this in a box actually this is headshot
we got a donation of books and this
picture was in a box and he works here
yeah and he wasn't here that day we
opened up the box and that was sitting
right on top and we were like oh my god
what's the chances of that
my name is email and I'm the warehouse
Foreman here
you look at a stack of books like this
that's almost 200 boxes of books and you
figure there's 20 books in each box you
do the math is hundreds of thousands of
books in here
no the stacks never get smaller it just
keeps growing and growing and growing in
here it's unbelievable like to organize
this place it's it's it's a lot of work
so you want to go back around go through
this way yeah it's like a maze I used to
work at Book Soup for 40 years before I
came here it was a good place to work
when I first started there they got
bought by another company called bromans
in Pasadena and it became a little more
corporate all these like independent
stores started they just started going
down even the the big you know
conglomerate started going down as well
so for Josh to like start a bookstore in
this day and age it took a lot of guts
you know what I mean and he started from
the ground up and you know made a good
place for people to work and I mean I
couldn't ask for anything more I'm like
really happy here so that's a good
experience a good job
I just love dealing with books you know
why wouldn't you want to work with
something that you love if I didn't make
any money at all I'd want to do this
it's sort of a hobby that turned into a
business and became a little bit of an
obsession and I just enjoy it so it
doesn't feel like work to me and that's
that's always the best kind of job right
when you just feel like you're having
fun and it's like what you would do as a
hobby anyways
I moved to Los Angeles in 2002 I think
shortly after my parents divorced and a
girlfriend broke up with me I had torn
my bicep like the year before and I had
like an Internet magazine covering film
and music and that sort of tanked I
tried to get a job a few places but
nobody would really hire me and so I
just I lived on welfare and food stamps
and I had sort of an early like midlife
crisis where I was just like man I'm a
loser
I'm not doing anything with my life I
gotta get serious about this it's gonna
find something that that I can really
focus on and really love and really get
behind you know I've always been a
writer and a reader and said I thought
well try books
[Music]
eBay was just getting started so I had
learned how to use that so I started
doing that just from my apartment this
tiny little studio apartment but this
one guy that that I knew his friend of
mine he kept hassling me to open up a
store for a couple of years really
until finally I relented and was like
all right just there's a space open up
across the street from where I live and
it was busy from the first day we opened
our doors
I created this place as as somewhere
that I would want to hang out all the
time you know I was like a huge living
room for me so it seems to have worked
for a lot of other people too so they
they kind of see it as their their home
away from home too you know I definitely
thing the bookstore has changed other
people's lives it's definitely become a
refuge for a lot of people regardless of
whether they like books or not it's a
place they come and hang out some of
them are huge book lovers so it's sort
of rejuvenated they're there
ability to access books easily people
who love books and love to read and love
to ord books and love to collect books
and definitely I think changed their
lives because they come here every
single day so whatever they were doing
before every single day they're not
doing that anymore
[Music]
we've tried to add a real human element
we want it to be an authentic real
experience versus something that's cold
and calculated
I think that's the difference I think
that's one reason why we've been able to
do well in other bookstores perhaps are
struggling
in the beginning I really did this think
okay I'm gonna do this sort of art
project bookstore in my last two or
three years and then it's gonna fail
because the book cos is gonna be done
and that'll be it but after my injury my
life perspective definitely changed in
terms of just learning to look at
everything as a challenge not be afraid
of failure
I've lost things in my life much more
traumatic than a business there's not
much that could compete with that
Harrison you know I can deal with that I
could certainly deal with a business
failing no big deal so
yeah no fair
[Music]